hey guys i'm ryan right so today i'm
checking out the trailer the official
one for san andreas the third one now
this movie is a scary plot yes
the trailers having quite scared me
because they just look like a typical
disaster film the more I think about
this happen cuz I live in California so
the more I think about this happening
the more it kind of freaks me out but
you know Dwayne the Johnson Rock or
whatever how you saying he will always
save the day so if this happens I'm glad
to know the rock lives in California six
hundred documented rescues that's pretty
impressive
and assitant you're taking off the blade
for a few days
yeah tomorrow I'm gonna try the backup
to school I can't believe she's in
college people are sleeping with his
daughter hi everything okay I wanted to
tell you I was sorry for how I acted
yesterday no wrong time to get in a
fight buddy
oh that would be pretty terrified middle
this whole chunk of land will be
decimated are you saying the whole San
Andreas Fault might come up yes that's
exactly what
we can't stop it we can't prepare for it
yeah
it will be a local
oh no that trailer was a lot scarier
than the ones I saw okay so they got a
good establishment of a character I like
how this isn't some guy who used to be a
rescue pilot now he is still doing that
job so it does make more sense now how
he's able to like swerve past falling
buildings and save a bunch of people cuz
normally it's like this is what this guy
used to do and now he has to take care
of his family but this is establishing a
front that yes this is his job so it
makes sense how he can actually save the
day a lot more the film looks scary like
the tone of it is very terrifying a lot
of the time these disaster movies are
all just about spectacle and awesome
visual effects which is what this has
but with the tone they're striking it
actually feels like this is a haunting
experience I love that shot where Gina
kirino's like the building's falling
apart she walks outside and then the
camera starts panning around you start
seeing all these buildings falling going
into the pool that [ __ ] was pretty
[ __ ] terrifying
I don't know why in these movies that
dad always has like the hottest [ __ ]
daughter alive and you know she's
probably a [ __ ] but they don't ever
cover that in the movie I want her to
survive though that last scene where
she's caught inside of the water and he
can't break through the door I really
hope that the audience gets that a
reward and she survives because that is
so sad whenever someone loses her kid in
a movie it's depressing makes for a
great drama but it's it's really
depressing can plus you know she's Logan
Luhrmann's girlfriend Logan Lerman
what's it continue getting his ball
sucked he needs her around my
girlfriends in the other room I know she
really likes this show anyway ratings
I'm I will definitely be going to see
San Andreas
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter if I get enough followers I can
do product placement so let's start off
with some product placement already for
products I hope to get placement on
hello I can hear you perfectly with my
new iPhone huh it's an iPhone 5 but if
only I could get a 6 if only some
company out there was like hey if he
gets a 6 more people might be inclined
to get an iPhone 6 remember when Adam
and he bit into that Daniel Lucas
you wanted a shout out he said Ryan
right you're awesome you spelled your
possessively you said why oh you are not
why oh you ' r-e I think Daniel you
should go back to school take some
proper grammatical lessons I don't know
if grammatical is a word take some
proper grammar lessons mm-hmm clearly I
have taken them too
look if you don't want to end up like me
like yes this channel has over a hundred
thousand subscribers now but I I didn't
even finish high school so what do I do
I just watch movies and trailers all day
do you really want that kind of life do
you really want an income off of just
working like a few hours a day and just
looking at trailers and movies and
giving your opinions on them it's a hard
life it's a hard life Daniel and I don't
want that for you